here's a question refinery29 asks how
much should you talk about your ex with
the new person you're dating people are
split right down the middle some say
never
you got to make it all about the one
you're with and others say and i guess
it's healthy to talk about exes you can
learn even more about each other and
know how to do things better this time
around rossi what are your thoughts well
i think you know your past and the
people you have been with are part of
who you are now you know right if you go
through some stuff you got some scars on
it you have to be able to to find the
value in that you bring a lot of that to
any new relationship now that being said
it should not feel like your ex is on
the date always your new relationship so
you have to find a little bit you know
if it's something important to you and
say hey you know i know this is a
trigger for me because of my past
relationships this that's good but if
you were like oh jeremy loved that do
you love that too that's what jeremy
would order oh i missed jeremy jeremy's
not here girl
let him go i totally agree it's all kind
of in tone amount and like past present
future
here's one thing that i learned early on
i was dating this guy jamie walters wait
wait wait wait wait
um how do you talk to an angel jimmy
walter how do you talk to an angel jamie
walter from like melrose place oh i love
jamie walters you live my team fantasy
yeah
um well one day sorry jamie but i opened
up his trunk and he would always be like
don't look in the trunk and i so i was
like oh god i think i was like what's in
the trunk what was in the trunk just
pictures letters his life that he had
brought so we could move him together
and i closed the trunk lid and i said i
will never do this again
it was the worst feeling i crossed a
line i hated myself for it now i never
ever i don't over ask i don't look
through i don't check phones i'm i've
never been that person because i learned
that feeling
was so not for me what about if you're
on a date with somebody now and they
start bringing up their ex is that like
a red flag or just a little itty bitty
pink one and more on the subject of the
refinery 29 story and not going through
my ex-boyfriend's trunk yeah okay so
yeah i think it's weird
i think it's really the amount are you
bringing them into the thing
is there too much you know here's what i
also learned
i think this is the reason i opened the
trunk in the first place was also don't
stress about a person's past they can't
change it there's no time machine please
honor the life that they lived before
they decided to be with you and that's
really what i learned from the trump yes
because they wouldn't be
you wouldn't be here where you are now
if you won't go through it
do not beat them up about something they
cannot change so celebrate your past
but don't bring it too much into the
present understood understood love it
couldn't agree more
hey i don't look through your
ex-boyfriend's trunk
hey don't do it uh so it's been you know
in the pandemic a lot of people have
been sort of wearing elastic and
sweatpants anyone here guilty of that
yes i know
well there's a new trend style for
anyone who's in the mood to start
feeling a little fancy pure wow reports
the opera glove
is climbing up forearms everywhere yes
remember okay back in the 16th century
opera gloves were worn exclusively by
rich ladies they were a sign of wealth
and the baby soft hands you get from
never doing manual labor okay much like
mine right now okay um
but just my moisturizer uh but today
they're for everybody all right look
celebrities are wearing them i'm rolling
up my sleeves oh i should take off my
rings too oh rossi wow
[Applause]
i don't think i'm thin enough
[Music]